texas is bracing for a massive surge of
up to 60 000 migrants at the southern
border which could be the largest group
ever to attempt to illegally enter the
united states from mexico and amid a
record surge in illegals apprehended at
the border president biden's dhs just
terminated the border wall contracts in
the laredo and rio grande valley former
president trump started the construction
of the border wall and at a rally last
night he named the border crisis as just
one of many for biden watch
after just nine months under biden
violent criminals and bloodthirsty gangs
are taking over our streets
illegal aliens and deadly drug cartels
are taking over our borders
inflation is taking over our economy
china's taking over our jobs the taliban
has taken over afghanistan
lunatic leftists are taking over our
schools and radical socialists are
taking over our country as disastrous as
the biden administration has been
no one can blame the
great state of iowa because boy we did
really we did really good here
[Applause]
joe that was a pretty good rundown there
and for a president for us right now who
campaigned on being a unifier in chief
it seems as if he is dedicated to two
things incompetence and also absolutely
dismantling every single thing that the
prior president put inflate in place
included of course are all of the border
wall contracts and it seems that he
is ignoring any prior program or policy
that was actually serving well and
serving good regardless of what party is
identified with the person behind
putting that policy in place so what do
you see here happening now that he's
terminating all of these border wall
contracts
is that for me emily yep joe okay great
i'm sorry i'm so distracted how well
we're matching right now as far as the
other pink thing is concerning
uh look a quinnipiac poll released last
week and it was devastating shows that
the biden harris administration is
pulling at 23 approval on their handling
of the border and and i'd love to sit
down and have some boone strawberry
speaking of strawberry with the 23 who
somehow think that things are going well
down there and the surges to your point
to your read emily it's only increasing
meanwhile the president can travel 23
times to delaware since the beginning of
the year but has yet to travel to the
border in his 50 years in government all
this while his vice president who once
compared ice to the kkk is m.i.a at the
border wtf not lol as we go full acronym
on this one but
one would think i know you like akron's
emily
that they wouldn't continue to make
every wrong decision on securing the
border and bringing sanity back to
running the country and forcing the
walls in the books but sure enough they
won't leading some on the right and it's
beginning to be a fair question i
thought it wasn't at first but how do
you ignore 2.3 million people coming
into the country in one year and that's
the pace we're on right now is this
intentional at this point because it
doesn't seem like they have any interest
in fixing this problem
right it's sort of like in law how you
when there's a negligence standard
there's such a thing as so much
negligence it becomes critical criminal
like it becomes absolutely ludicrous and
aisha as we were just talking about a
moment ago this administration maintains
that its highest priority is kovit right
its highest priority is managing every
single thing that flows from the
pandemic and that is why they have
restricted so many liberties and
freedoms and the like and so how does
that fit in with the fact that they are
ignoring essentially what is occurring
on the southern border for example the
almost 15 000 haitian migrants that
surged across the border in the last few
weeks that's coming from a country with
a less than one percent vaccination rate
this administration allows for all of
these illegal migrants coming over to
have an over 30 percent vaccination
declination rate the spread of their the
transmission is over 6 percent they
close new york city public schools at 3
percent so how does that even fit with
their maintaining that covid is their
highest priority yeah i think you know
this is this is not a political
um
problem here i think everyone can agree
that our hearts break for these people
um and the position that they're sort of
put in as they cross the border one
um
you know sitting next to each other
under a bridge as we saw not too long
ago but then also you know the way the
cartels are taking advantage of the
situation i've been down there twice um
and i've obviously seen the equipment
and the materials uh to build a border
wall just sitting there and rotting away
um and obviously now we found out
through our brilliant bear that we were
spending about five million dollars a
day to not build the border wall but um
i want to just make sure that we don't
forget that the problem that we're not
confronting right now are the cartels
and that is what you would hear from the
border patrol agents and henry cuellar a
congressman from this district who is a
democrat by the way not for the border
wall but for border security would like
to see some of this money
that's now going to be diverted
somewhere else would like to see that
spent on technology on on finding ways
to better protect the border from the
cartels and whether that's cameras or
lighting or adding more border patrol
agents but we really need to center the
conversation back on the cartels because
it's the cartels that are really taking
advantage of the situation and advantage
of all of these people that eventually
some of them will be trafficked you know
will not be able to live the american
dream once they get into this country
will be abused right guy aisha makes
such a great point there are such a
complex web of factors of push and pull
factors there at the southern border not
least of which is the human smuggling
industry which is the largest global
illicit industry besides drugs that the
cartels are freely seizing upon pushing
so many thousands
hundreds of thousands of people across
the border reign of terror we have again
a commander-in-chief who touted his
almost 50-year experience in government
as part of his international savvy as
part of the diplomacy required to
work with mexico and those central
american countries and governments to
help manage those national or
international transnarco cartels and yet
nothing is happening again and now
they're dismantling contracts and
putting the money towards environmental
factors you can't make this up guy
now the policies are just breathtaking
and i want people to think about this
right if you look at the economy right
now we have very disappointing job
numbers that just came out on friday we
have growth not meeting expectations we
have inflation hitting americans in
their pocketbooks and their bottom lines
and the policy solution from the
democratic party from the white house on
those fronts are to raise taxes on job
creators and to spend trillions more
dollars in an age of inflation those are
just i think to me shockingly bad ideas
under any circumstance but especially
under these circumstances
you apply that to the border and the
crisis that we're seeing down there what
are the things that biden has done at
the border
number one he has now stopped and cut
off all funding and contracts for
building a barrier a wall that i think i
understand people don't like trump and
they don't like his slogan they want to
distance themselves from building the
wall because of that tribalism but when
you watch people just walking across
into our country it's hard to argue that
some barrier or wall would not help but
they won't do that because of political
reasons and secondly they have canceled
and terminated the remain in mexico
policy which was one of the single most
successful trump-era policies on the
books that helped get a previous crisis
under control they've abandoned it
entirely even though
it's on its face it has manifestly
worked they aren't interested in that
and over and over again they put
politics ahead of successful policy and
it is an extremely frustrating thing to
watch
that's exactly right this
administration's answer to everything is
to take away your liberties take away
your money and then to blame you or the
prior president for anything that goes
wrong hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else